hello and welcome to another edition of
The Gadget Lab podcast I'm Michael
colori and I am John Phillips John what
is that unusually handsome device you're
wearing around your wrist this is the
jawbone up and we had this on the show
before I may remember Brian Chen had it
a couple of months ago he talked about
it when we first got a preview of it
we've gotten a test unit and you're
testing it right I am testing it I put
it on last night and what this thing is
I'm not sure what the industry term for
it is but it's a bracelet and it's sort
of like a like health health stats
monitoring device right it's sort of a
health and wellness bracelet so you wear
it 24 7 it's completely waterproof and
so I word in the shower this morning and
there's a bunch of electronics inside an
accelerometer and a lot of data
acquisition tools for lack of a better
term and it can record how many steps
you take during the course of a day and
it has this real cool feature that I
that I did try in-depth overnight where
you hit a button right before you go to
bed and then it will track your sort of
periods of REM sleep and deep sleep and
the next morning you wake up you connect
this to your iPhone slips right into the
headphone jack it downloads all the data
and it tells you how long you slept how
well you slept so yeah it basically it
tells you what's going on in the middle
of the night and what's going on during
the day as far as exercise and the
number of steps you take that's cool and
all the all the data gathering and all
the analysis and everything happens
within our iPhone app right so it's the
up iPhone app you download it directly
from the app store it's free the
bracelets 100 bucks but the app is free
right app is free and there's this other
other cool feature where your friends
could ition you issue you challenges so
you could send me a tweet or whatever
sort of messaging the software uses and
say hey John I challenge you to take
extra six thousand steps today which
forces me to get out of my gadget lab
seat walk around the block a few times
and
sort of meat fat meat that benchmark
that's cool yeah yeah so I'm really
digging it so far it's sort of
competitive with the Fitbit as far as
the pedometer functions its competitive
with the sleep tracker watch as far as
the nighttime on sort of biometric
feedback functions it hasn't been up
true civ on my wrist so far people think
it looks pretty cool and actually it's a
great advertisement for the product
itself people walk by hey what the hell
is that yeah you could describe it so
there's no bright yellow one so they
won't confuse it with the loot stronger
all right it does come in a few
different colors they're all sort of
muted yeah it's high-tech in a very
modern way so i thought i saw a demo of
this last week and the thing that i
liked about it is the way that attracts
don't you eat right you take a picture
of everything you eat and then a couple
of hours later it asks you how do you
feel right so you take a picture of your
you know carnitas burrito mahato and
then a couple hours later and ask you
how do you feel you tell it terrible and
then it'll go it'll obviously gather all
that and it will let you know like you
know that you usually feel terrible
after you eat right and I need to spirit
Omaha via the iOS app sort of has this
this three-pronged timeline that shows
that sort of reveals your sleep patterns
over a period your exercise patterns and
this whole food feedback loop thing that
they got going on you know the jawbone
sort of concedes that the food portion
of it is it as fully developed as the
other two but they say they're in
continuing development and that
everything should improve you know the
whole taking pictures of your food thing
that's kind of interesting that it
launched this week because also
launching this week was a new app from
massive health the startup it's called
the eatery it's an iphone app where you
take pictures of what you eat and then
it shows you what your weaknesses are
and what times days you tend it what
times of day you tend eat works and so
have you uh have you downloaded it and I
had a shot I have yes what have we
learned I I have not really learned much
yet because I'm only taking one picture
but report back later so enough about
the up we're going to take a look at
some some freaky robotic vacuum cleaners
probably seeing these robot vacuum
cleaners before and wondered if they
actually work the fact the matter is
they're not going to compete with the
mop bucket and some elbow grease but if
you don't have the coin to get a maid
and you don't the time at the end of the
day to clean up your house please make a
great alternative this is the iRobot
Roomba this is the original it came out
back in the early 2000s it's got a all
the dirt comes into this container on
the back here bristles underneath here
will abdicate pretty much any speck of
dust or dander that's in your carpet in
this little part right here elysian came
off of the street sweeper goes
underneath appliances and around corners
to get every little speck off pit just
want to run you between 400 and 600
dollars depending on the model yet this
is the neato robotics home vacuum
cleaner this beast is shipped with a
flat front to accommodate this big and
very noisy scooper right here it runs
the only foreigner bucks it'll agitate
just about anything out of a carpet in
front of it it unlike the other ones is
nimble around corners so when it hits
something it takes a little longer to
get around this is the LG home bud
probably the winner in the swimsuit
category for all of these this thing has
a similar structure of the Roomba it's
got these hard bristles underneath here
and the side sweeper right here to get
underneath appliances and around corners
it unlike the other ones doesn't have a
collapsible front echoes based off of
the readings from these sensors on the
front here so it doesn't actually
collapse in any way which means fewer
moving parts you pay a premium for it
though the LG will cost you about seven
hundred dollars if you're fortunate
enough to not have to worry about
carpeting in all and the other option is
the mint here this one's a dedicated
hardwood
floor cleaner it pushes along these
Swiffer like machine washable cloths on
the frontier small compact package the
only other caveat is that you have to
have this thing this cube you set it on
top of the counter and helps the main
triangulate its position this one's
cheaper too it runs about two hundred
dollars so which one's the best it
depends on which what you're looking for
in a robot vacuum cleaner if you're
dealing with just hardwood floors the
mint is hard to beat it's cheap and it's
a very fashion at picking up dog hair
dust anything that ends up on your
linoleum floor if you want to save
yourself a little bit of money the neato
robotics home vacuum cleaner works but
it sounds like a jet turbine engine they
pay the cost that way the LG wins the
beauty contest it's about as good as the
neato but both of them they get beat by
the iRobot Roomba the original is still
the best it'll pick up with the other
ones have left behind and I'll get every
little nook and cranny that you need and
it's not nearly as loud as the rest of
them you're in the market for a home
robot vacuum cleaner and you have both
carpet and hardwood floors go with the
iRobot Roomba it's the original and
still the best and i'll pick up with all
the other ones leave behind alright so
we've seen devices that will track your
health and sleep habits we've seen
devices that will automatically clean
your floors now here is advice for
regulating the temperature inside your
home right ok it's a thermostat this is
the nest thermostat from nest labs we
did a huge story on it a couple of weeks
ago and it essentially is a learning
thermostat so you remove the existing
thermostat from your wall this goes in
plug in the correct wires and there's a
whole big video on Escom on how to do
this correctly and if you don't think
you can do it yourself because you don't
want to turn off the electricity in your
house they will send out a service
person to help you anyway you get that
installed you plot this on top and you
set it going and in effect what it's
supposed to do is learn all your
thermostat habits when you like a cold
when you like it hot one how you like it
in the middle of the night
and it will sort of learn those
behaviors and adjust to them and
supposedly deliver the perfect
thermostat program for you over a course
of a few days so is about keeping you
comfortable or is it about you know
saving energy right it's well
theoretically supposedly it's both so
it's supposed to keep you more
comfortable and it does have these
energy-saving features so for example if
the way it's being described is it's
sort of like the Toyota Prius where you
could watch your dash display and learn
how to sort of modulate the way you use
the brakes and the gas to generate more
battery power and so like that you can
set the thermostat and when you hit it
to a certain point this little green
leaf comes up the green leaf tells you
hey you're now saving energy so it's
supposed to sort of train you to be more
in turn ignition I see sort of like how
the Prius tells you now you're running
on all electricity and exotic ladies and
gas and then it comes to this curious
little gadget we didn't know exactly
what it is looks like some kind of eye
dropper see I thought I thought this was
a device for catching your tears because
you're crying because you can't believe
how beautiful your thermostat is but no
oh look at that it's actually it's the
little tool kit that comes with it such
a bummer yeah you have everything you
need to install this in your wall so not
only did they design the perfect
beautiful thermostat but they designed a
more perfect screwdriver right and this
was all sort of the creation of the guy
who designed the original ipod for apple
he moved over to nestle ads and this is
his sort of big new celebrity gadget
product so does it do lots of streaming
it should you write a children or i'm
just going to attach it to my wrist and
it's going to be my new you know fashion
accessory for the tech for the tech cast
yeah there's there's an app for that
John yeah uh well you're going to test
it out for us and you tell us how it is
that's right so we're installing it this
weekend and we'll give it a whirl make
sure I spent enough time with it to
really get an idea on how it works
whether it's working how intuitive it is
what the AI is like and it will appear
as review soon enough all right well we
can't wait for that and
until next time we back with more gadget
news and more cool products show off and
see you next time